I'd now like to talk about the velocity
of the center of mass for a system of
particles so let's take a system which
I'll just outline by this and in that
system we have a bunch of particles
particle 1 particle - that's refer to
this as the J particle and some point x
cm and if I want to talk about the
position of the center of mass I can
choose a point s and if I want to define
that vector R cm then what I have to do
is draw a vector to each object our s J
and we saw that this velocity the
position of the center of mass with
respect to this origin s is the sum MJ r
SJ and that's divided by the total mass
M total and J goes from 1 to n where n
is the number of particles in the system
now if I want to find the velocity of
the center of mass then I can just
differentiate this and I'm dropping the
point s for the moment but let's just
differentiate 1 to N you'll see why and
when I differentiate the position vector
of the object that's the velocity of the
object divided by j goes from 1 to n the
total mass now why did I drop a position
because if you have any two fixed points
so if I chose another fixed point say
over here P then this distance are
called vector from s to P RSP this is a
constant and if I draw the position
vector with respect to P now the point
here is that this is constant distance
because this is a fixed these are fixed
points
then if you were to draw your vector
triangle which is the position of the
object with respect to s that's this
vector is equal to that fixed position
vector from s to P plus the vector from
P to J and I differentiate this DRS J DT
well this derivative of a constant
vector this is zero plus d RP j DT and
so we see that the velocity J is
independent of the choice of point s you
choose any other fixed point and you get
that these velocities the RS j dt equals
dr p j dt for all fixed points p and
that's why in this expression when we
differentiate the velocity even though
we had an index s we drop that and so
our conclusion is that we can treat that
we have the velocity of the center of
mass of this system is equal to the sum
m j bj j goes from 1 to n divided by the
total mass now what's interesting here
is why is this an important quantity
let's just add that if we want to talk
about the acceleration of the center of
mass I do exactly the same type of
calculation I just differentiate and I
get the mass of the jth particle times
the acceleration of the J the particle
divided by the total mass and our next
step is to understand why this is an
important quantity for a system of part